thank you very much for the invitation
it's always
good to be back in berkeley
um
so
if you have a productive variety
it's an interesting question to
determine the arithmetic rank
which is just the minimal number of
equations needed to cut out x set
theoretically
um or another way to say it is the
minimal
t such that
the defining ideal
of x
is generated up to radical by
by these t
equations okay
so
just to relate to greg stark from this
morning
this has nothing to do with greg stock
from this morning so arithmetic rank is
not
extreme
it's a different concept okay excuse me
it's a security
yes so that's why i put the radical over
there by the way i'm just going to work
over complex numbers today
it's another difference from
today's talk okay um
so
maybe one thing that's that's uh
the similarity between the arithmetic
rank and the usual rank is that you
always get an upper bound
given by the dimension of the ambient
space that's the theorem
by eisenbud
in evans and you can also get a lower
bound just given by the co-dimension of
x
and the reason is whenever you cut with
an equation you can only drop dimension
by one
okay
and
if you have an equality here if this is
an equality we just say that x is a set
theoretic
a complete intersection
just the minimal number of equations
suffices to
i mean
this lower bound is attained okay
so let me just give you an example maybe
you haven't seen it before if you look
at the arithmetic rank
so what are the hypotheses on x sorry
it's just the algebraic variety
you can assume
i
i don't have to assume it's irreducible
but reduced
that's what my question is it's
it's it's it's a veronese
when i say algebraic variety i mean
reduced and irreducible in the soul
we're going to talk about but sort of
what i mean
i guess
i mean this is about evans can't be true
for
if
not so it's reduced
so if i assume reduce then this is true
if i assume reduce then this is true
without reduced and irreducible i don't
have to assume your disability what if i
take a collection of points that's not a
complete intersection
well
when i intersect i'm going to get the uh
knowledge structure on that
so i can find out any equations and oh
oh oh oh oh okay so it's a theoretical
instance
yes i see
sorry okay
so um
if i do this for for matrices of rank
smaller than p so let's say m by n
matrices
then what you find is that this is m n
minus p squared plus one
and the co dimension
minus p times n minus p
so
there is a classical
um
last one
it's a classical example and
and let me do an even more basic one if
you take c
to be a twisted cubic
uh
then uh
well the idea looks in p3 so the ideal
let me just see what this is this is the
image of the third veronese embedding of
p1
then
the ideal of c is defined
by three equations
which are just the two by two minors
of this matrix
the zs are the coordinates on p3
but as i said actually
you only need two equations so this is
just a determinant
this equation maybe it's a
fun exercise to do if you get bored
if you set these two equations to be
zero then your point is in the image of
the parametrization okay so actually
this c is a set theoretic
of the intersection
uh whereas this is that this matrices
are usually not
okay
and actually
vala
proved
that uh any rational normal curve
not just the two-state cubic
is a set complete intersection
and also the secant varieties of this so
this is just if you want tensor
symmetric tensors of rank one
two variables
okay so just
i want to emphasize that computing
arithmetic rank is actually a very
complicated problem let me just uh
ask a question
very interested in
is actually not a name for this two
weeks
when i'm here
it wasn't planned
yes i think so
so this the question is if i look at not
the the degree three rational curve a
degree four rational curve in p3
such as the image
this map
let's change the
three of the four
what what's the arithmetic rank
well it's it's a most free that's
eisenberg in events and it's at least
two because that's the co-dimension
we don't know how to answer that okay
so why does fortune care about this
well i mean
if you can do this first example i mean
i i don't think there's any there's any
example of a smooth
curve
in p3
uh
that's known to not be a security
complete intersection
i mean it's just one of the first
examples we should
probably before moving forward we should
try to solve this
and sort of what's the general approach
if you want
to to to to arithmetic rank
well you try to get lower bounds
and upper bounds like i did
and well
lower bounds
are usually given by chromological
obstructions
and to get upper bounds
kind of have to produce equations
so just come up with equations
if you want to do better then
then this general bound by either button
and
and coming up with equations is is
really
more more of an art
maybe maybe georgia and jm can tell you
more about some of the equations for
interesting varieties so what i want to
do is i want to focus
on one chromological obstruction
so i'm really not going to give you any
new results about the arithmetic rank
that's just a
sort of some of my motivation but i i'll
focus on computing
uh
some chromological abstraction which is
local core knowledge and i'll describe
that
very quickly yes uh so in all the
discussions you don't really care what
degrees your equations come yeah
so
but is there any notion i mean that
doesn't happen i mean okay
but does it happen though when you know
what's happening with eric merritt right
does it happen that equations come in
low degree anyway
or are there examples where you really
need to take things of very high degree
and no low degree equations
i mean it's not a very precise question
yes no i don't i don't
i think we can prove lower bounds for
the
degrees of the equations that you need
i mean for
in this example for example they're
definitely higher than degree p you have
to go up but
so they're financing many so then
they're bounded degrees
uh yeah i mean no it's a very good
question
in the sense that you would like to
maybe first figure out the lower uh an
upper bound for the
for the
set uratic generating degree right and
then and then start to look for
for examples in the lower degrees right
yes you can also fix the degrees and ask
the same question right that's the same
question yes
i always think does the question
simplify in co-dimension two
um
well but this is called dimension too
what this is co-dimension too right but
the general question
oh you mean whether it reduces to the
curve or no so
you started out for general
arbitrary variety
and you ask you know how do you find
upper lower bounds for this
arithmetic rank
and now i'm saying that you have a
variety of co-dimension two
are there better bounds than what you've
told us
oh there's there's all it i mean there's
the
oh it's co-dimension too correction
i guess i have another example yeah
there's no better or there's
yeah but maybe in in larger dimensions
you could have mentioned to something
you know
well i don't yeah i don't think so
we have to yeah i don't i don't have an
answer
okay so i said i'm just going to look at
one
again everything was motivation what i
want is i want to look at at uh one
chromological obstruction and that's
that's local homology i want to describe
it for you and i want to talk about
computing
so
if you have an ideal
then you define the the local chromology
groups
that's just the homology
of the chick complex
that you get well you start off with the
polynomial ring and then you map to the
direct sum
localizations
uh at this generators
and then
localizations of products of two
generators and so on
the complex of length t
homology groups of this complex
are the the local homology modules
and um
well the fact
to note here
is that uh
the local commodity modules only depend
on the
uh
common zero locus of this fis
as it said so
this only depends
on the zeros
of the polynomials i
and um
so in particular they're the same if two
ideas are the same up to radical
so in particular
non-vanishing of local chromology gives
you lower bounds for the number of
equations because if you can cut
down your x by five equations then the
check complex is going to have
length five
um
which means local chromology is going to
vanish from degree 6 on
right so
so
a lower bound for arithmetic rank
so
if i call this x
a lower bound
for arithmetic rank will be the
chromological dimension
of x which is just the
largest degree
such that local comology vanishes in
that
oh sorry it's not zero
and the second remark to make is that
actually
these are s modules but but they're very
non-finitely generated so if you think
of them as s modules
you need an infinite amount of data to
to to capture them but
but but if you enlarge the ring
and think of them as
if you make if you replace this as by
the vowel algebra
of differential
operators
i'll call this d
um
then every term in this complex is a d
module because it makes sense to
differentiate
a fraction of polynomials and when you
differentiate the denominator
i mean if the denominator had an f i in
the
if the denominator have the power of f i
and you differentiate you're only going
to increase that power so it's still
going to be
in the localization so all the terms
here are closed under differentiation
their d modules the
uh
the restriction maps which i didn't tell
they just come from inclusions
uh so they're given by constants so they
will commute with taking differentials
so this is really a complex of d modules
which means that the homology the local
homology groups are going to be d
modules so it's the second fact
which i want to use just to think of
this as finite objects
so the local chromology modules
are d modules
and actually
they're not just finitely generated but
they have finite length
uh
well technically we call them holonomic
but this is not important so the
important thing is as modules over this
bigger algebra they're going to have a
finite filtration where the quotients
are simple
so um
so what i want to do
is i want to study
these local chromology modules what do i
mean by that well
they
studied them right
maybe i mean to determine when they're
non-zero
this will have to do with the discussion
from before it will at least give me
some lower bounds
for uh
for arithmetic rank uh but i could also
try to understand
the module structure
the composition series the symbols that
appear in the quotients of a filtration
so
and in situations where you have
symmetry coming from a group action
which is most concrete situations i'd
like to understand the g equivalent
structure
so any hope of using these modules for
getting
upper bounds
i'll give you a theorem which might say
there's
a little hole
depending on whether you're optimistic
or pessimistic
but
the story is real right now so it was
very frank does it it does not
it's not obvious to me that having a
group action helps you
so that's why i said this this
motivation i'm just going to talk about
computing the local homology and when
you compute local homology
just the the act of computing it
might
get some help from the group action so i
want to talk about an example
and there's many examples like
can i comment like for matrices where
you you couldn't compute focal homology
if you didn't take into account the
other group structure yes
let's say anything about the question
about coordination two so there was this
famous conjecture by hashem that the
pack is smooth that's why
yeah so it's so cool yeah but even
stronger than that the reason the
conjecture in co-dimension two is easier
than the general hardcore conjecture
is because in co-dimension two you can
reduce it to question about rank two
vector bundles
and you don't have that in higher code
dimension so that that was why i asked
i guess that's still hard yeah i'm sure
i mean you could have mentioned two the
question the hard chord conjecture is
just whether every ranked two vector
model splits the direct sum of line
models which is
appears to be easier than the general
conjecture rolled out and both are open
today is the day they were made
can i can i ask questions yes so if i
want to do this computation even just
computing s sub f i as a d model is a
non-trivial calculation yeah just
computing the functions and i've created
all things
so
so i mean if i just ask this in a very
general context it's there's basically
no hope i mean there you can try to use
the module
packaging macaulay too it's not gonna go
i don't think it's gonna give you the
two by two miners of it
not even that
i don't think so i mean
when we computed the local commodity
with supporting ideals of miners that
wasn't
so yeah i mean
it's a hard question to actually compute
it and that's why i'm not going to do it
except for
for in some examples
okay so i said the g equivalent
structure i mean
this modules have a g action they're
representations of the group and so i'll
understand how g acts on them so so this
makes sense when
there's a g action
on the polynomial ring and on the ideal
that's that's
compatible
so
today i'm just going to focus on one
example
uh and that example is
when x is a very nice cone
this is the cone over the
degree d
of
veronese embedding
um if i want to
write this in a
coordinate free
way then i can just think of x as the
image
of the embedding
or
not embedding but it's just a map
which
this w is a vector space of of dimension
n
and the map just takes a
element of the vector space think of it
as a linear form and it raises it to the
d power
okay
so i sort of want to try to
take that x i is the ideal defining idea
of x
what do you mean by kona you're taking
in the fine
yes so this is the affine situation is
the image of this d power man
so it's a vector space this is another
vector
so that's the
the that's the
that's x
the cone over the variance of right and
the group acting
is just all the linear
changes of coordinates on double
uh so
just to
make sure everybody's happy with this
coordinate tree
in the notation i'm going to take v to
be the dual of w so just linear forms
on v
on w sorry and then
the polynomial ring that i'm talking
about is the homogeneous ring of this
projective space
for the alpha coordinating of this
vector space this is the symmetric
algebra
and the ideal of x is an ideal in this
polynomial right
so there's a g election
and um
well not much happens
in terms of this question
so if i take uh nd to be the
co-dimension
let me just say
i'll make further notations let me just
say that
august show
that local chromology vanishes
except
the degree equal to the co co-dimension
of x
and then he also showed that
this
veronese cone or the verneza variety is
not a set theoretic
complete intersection
and the dimension of the vector space is
bigger than two so forth
for n equals two this is the rational
normal curves at which vala proved their
set here at the complete intersection
but then this is not
so i'll comment on this but let me just
state
theorem
one theorem
is that
that if you look
in degree called the code dimensions so
the only interesting one
then this is actually a simple
xp variant
the module so this is regardless of
whether we're looking at embeddings of
p1
or uh
or
higher projective spaces so in that
sense
this information about the structure
doesn't distinguish between
between
being as if you're at a complete
intersection or not
maybe there's more subtle structure that
you can find inside here
but i don't have
that you know what it is that's a glw
yes and i'll say some i'll say more
about this
so that's what i was going to say and
then be more precise later so it
decomposes into a sum of irreducible
representations
the infinite sum
but then these irreducible
representations are indexed by
dominant weight so
non
increasing sequences of integers and we
can describe
this alm does explicitly
so
again in terms of this non-vanishing
this is not giving you anything new
august new it
doesn't give you anything better than
the
co-dimension bound for arithmetic rank
so the reason why i'm talking about this
example is i just
want to give you a point of view which
you may apply to other concrete
situations
about computing
the d module structure
and and and and and and then
understanding non-vanishing in those
situations so again for
for sacred varieties this is no longer
going to be true
and you can apply the same techniques to
understand which of the occalconology
modules are known here
for mages is we basically did it with
wayman for for symmetric matrices you
should
go through this
and and
and and see what happens i don't have
time to explain
those cases i just want to focus on one
example
which again is not not so interesting in
terms of the non-vanishing but it's
interesting in how you get your hands on
this equivalent structure and how you
get your hands on the demand
instructions okay
okay
if you uh view that the module is a
purpose chief do you know what its
stocks are at various points
um
yes it so
i'll say
what this d module corresponds to is
just the
uh intersection homology shift that you
get from the trivia local system on the
orbit of non-zero teeth powers
and so then there's just the question of
computing if you're on the stock at
n0
but you know
i can't compute it i don't i can tell
you
and you can compute it because you can
do
i think you understand the the
decomposition theorem coming from the
resolution which is just the blow up and
i think if you do that
do you remember how does this one show
that it's not a
saturated compromise
uh so
then you get you can there's other ways
to get lower bounds from non-vanishing
orbital
chromos
this is how it gets better
lower bounds then
then local commodity
okay so
uh
what's this d module and then how do you
understand
the decomposition into irreducibles so
so it's a simple equivalent d module
with support
contained in this x
and there's a way to classify this the
modules as the equivariant
raymond hilbert correspondence
so i'm not going to tell you what this
is i'm just going to tell you that the
answer is
there's
t plus one possibilities
of the modules that may come up in the
description of local homology
and there's one what does it mean that
the support is contained in x
so you can talk about the
the support of a
uh
of a module which means every element is
so this if the support is inside x then
every element is killed by some power of
the defining idea of x
so then you can define support
and this has this property so the
modules that come up should have the
problem
so anyway there's a finite list
um
well this you might have seen this is
the injective envelope
of the residue field or
some people call it the graded dual of
the polynomial ring
it's a d module supported at
zero
and then there's these other ones
um
that have support
equal to the
full baron is a cone
they are classified by representations
of the component group of a stabilizer
of a death power so if you take a death
power if you look at the stabilizer
that's
the e1 to the d look at the stabilizer
this is matrices that in the upper left
corner have a root of unity of border d
so if you look at the component we
connect the components of that it's
going to give you give you a cyclic
group of order d there's the irreducible
representations of that this is where
the d's come from just two
so the point is yeah so e is the violent
algebra modulo the left style yield
generated by the yes that's right
right
and sort of
again this come from representations of
a cyclic group of order d
this is the trivial representation
so let me not say too much about exactly
what how they come up but then
but then this local homology is actually
zero that's the fact
so again this makes sense if you go look
at the cones over segreg products and
you will still get a d copy of d
zero inside the
these local como as your modules but
then they're you're going to get
a bunch of copies
of this module supported at zero which
are spread out in various chromological
degrees and then so you have to
understand that
the point is that in this case
there's just one
so now once i told tell you that
if you want to understand the gl
structure here you just have to
understand the decomposition of d zero
into irreducible representations can you
say one time what's this zero can you
describe it explicitly so it has
generators and relations for me no
that's a problem so it's not sick
no i mean it is sickly because they're
all so there's a left id yes they're all
they're all cyclic all these holonomics
so can you tell me something about the
left idea
no
could i compute it in principle given
enough
time and pound
maybe
but i mean the point is i can't get
directly to these the eyes you have to
do something
right so yeah i mean i would like
a presentation for this
so so when i talk about this um this uh
characters if aqua variant the modules i
just mean
understand how this d i's
decomposing into irreducible
representations and maybe understand how
e decomposes
so i mean just just because e
is simple so e is i said is the greater
dual so it's the symmetric algebra
on the
dual of sdv so on sdw
but then if you know something about
keeping track of equivalence you have to
you have to tensor with the
one-dimensional representation which is
just the the determinant of sdw
so this is the
the the
top exterior power of this vector space
so if i write it this way then then that
tells me how glw acts
if you want to
now if i want to talk about the
composition into reproducible then then
that should somehow be described into
in terms of the decomposition of these
platys symmetric powers of cmd
so this is
what i mean by by x by by describing the
lambdas i can describe them in terms of
certain plates well i mean that is not
explicit because we don't know how to
compute those
in some cases it would be explicit sure
and so i'll show it but there's no
closed
formula at all well this is the first
step and i
would be happy to get help about
getting a close formula that is about
computing for this
yeah that's all i can do huh
so in this theory
it's been zero
i first
i first determine the characters
and then
uh i compute local commonology by some
spectral sequence which i know nothing
about
just that i understand the
representation theory of the terms
and i understand that the final result
should have something to do with the di
and so i chase various irreducibles
in the spectral sequence
some of the terms i can take and
understand that there's only
so first of all so for example
understand that this representation
which shows up in e will never occur in
local homology so there's no e
and then some other representations that
that that
uh i can keep track of i can count their
multiplicities and i can understand
the number of times they appear in d
zero is the same as the number of times
they have here
so it's it's it's
again
the way in which i proved it is
completely different than the way in
which i tell you the story so i'd like
to test you one more time with the same
question yes d0 is the bile algebra
marginal or left ideal in this ideal i
have the varinase ideal in x yes
can you tell me one other element
tell me one element that actually has a
differential
in one example
uh in one example yes i can
so for uh for d equals two
just write down one diff one
differential operand in the idea that's
not actually from the variant
over d equals two is going to be some
determinant in the
dual variables
in the differential
yes so did during the d dt guys
some determine what kind of
maybe an n by n or n minus one we should
talk about it afterwards but
um
but sort of that's how it comes up
okay so um
so i said i wanna i have to tell you now
about how you get to the decomposition
or how do you get to the gl double
reaction maybe not the decomposition
that sort of something
say something about the multiplicities
w is d and n equal
no d it's not n
is the degree d versus a and w is an
n-dimensional vector space
so uh
so i have to to explain how you get this
a lambdas
well one way to get the lambdas
let me let me state formula
um
so again v is the dual of w
and then if you want to understand the
gl structure
on the dis
um you get it as follows
well you define
this if you want p power sums
so again this is some partition it makes
sense to talk about the sure function
apply to this
v
it's an alternating sum so this is just
a virtual representation
and it's in some growth empty group
and then one way to describe d0 is as
follows
this is just the limit
as r goes to infinity
r is congruent to zero mod d
of
p r v
times
i mean that for each
r for each r
i get a virtual representation so i take
this i decompose it with the glw
structure i'll get both positive and
negative coefficients
so i get some module m r
which which is the sum of a lambda r
is lambda
and as r goes to infinity
for a fixed lambda this coefficient
stabilizes
and when i talk about the limit
then what i mean is exactly the for each
lambda i mean the stable value for fixed
are there are some finishes that are the
in the definition of prv
it's fixed
it's a finite number of eyes
up to i equal r it's up to
r
the minimum of r minus 1 and
n minus 1.
so yes the finite sum i tensor with the
c and decompose take the limit
and that's that's the stable value
well this is probably not very
satisfying
but
you can compute
the stable values
in terms
of stable multiplicities
of playlist
of symmetric lattice
when the person part is large
yes this is when the first part is so
this is this is the rest you fix the
rest of it so this is due to manifest
and maybe since it's already
technical i'm not going to give it the
exact
i'm not going to give you the exact
formula
but so this is maybe one the first
iteration and then you have to
understand this stabilization to give
explicit
explicit formulas
and then let me just give one example
and then i'll
give up
so one example is when
when i talk about d equals two so
symmetric matrices
so there's an analogous formula for the
other di is if you remove this term and
then there's some
anyways so the example is when d equals
two
so i'm talking about um
one by one oh sorry rank one symmetric
matrices
then each di is going to decompose
into a sum of irreducible
representations all the multiplicities
are what zero or one
i just have to tell you which partitions
appear
and so that depends on whether
that is even or odd
they all
look very similar
the n minus first part has to be bigger
than n the last one is arbitrary they're
all even
for d1 you get the same thing just that
the last part
is odd
all right so it's something very
very explicit so here
i guess
and so so this may be the simplest case
in which you can actually write down
something and the point is
if you again if you do uh if you do
segres or sega veronesis
you you you can get sort of explicit
descriptions as long as you can
understand something about about
stabilizations
of symmetric powers of a tensor product
of symmetric cars in the vector space
and um
and that's hard
manny though has results completely
generally exactly yeah about the
stabilization oh yes stability
stabilization always occurs and then you
can describe this in terms of the stable
depth and one problem is that
unfortunately what this formula is going
to be is not going to be a positive
formula it's going to be still
an alternating sum for some of the
representations if you just want to show
some non-vanishing statement for some of
them the alternating sum reduces to only
one
piece and then that
in that case you can be more explicit
anyway this is the most explicit i can
get so
i'll stop here
any questions comments
sorry
okay first
so i i forgot to say i know i asked this
question last time i saw you give a talk
but it wasn't different it wasn't like
he said i think yes but with the same
question so like
how much did you know before computing
about this gl equivalent d module did
you know it was semi-simple already
no
so i think
there has to be some general results
about this but i think it's sort of even
the finite multiplicities i mean you
have to have some assumption on
on having finitely many orbits
okay um
so the group has to be large enough if
you want to play this game
so it's not just a simple d module
it's a community
i think this one is or at least for me
yes so
and that's how the
question behind this question was
you mentioned this decomposition theorem
and so on and this one is relation we
would share between these yes so could i
just take could i take the blow up
uh compute
local chromology somehow along
the exceptional
divisor and take global sections i
didn't have to say take push forward of
that with that i mean
um so in principle that's how you
is that the spectral sequence that
you're talking about this uh
oh no no sorry i was talking about uh
no for for this spectral sequence to
come yeah sorry i was
to compute this thing i i wanted a
filtration that refines the filtration
given by the powers of the ideals of i
or which is sort of easy to compute x
modules but i can't compute this
upstairs and then push down
well i don't know how to do that but
maybe
i mean
local homology
really supported on the exceptional
division yeah
uh why do i i mean the point would be
then to invoke the
change to a d module upstairs and then
vote the decomposition to go down
um
yeah but if you push forward that one
you will get this zero and you'll get
and you'll get other stuff
so i think there's a natural d module
that you can write down upstairs and
push it forward and you're not going to
get you'll get will you
necessarily get something of which this
is a summon
i'm just trying to understand how much
you're new from general principles and
how much you do
uh well i didn't know any general
principles
but i knew calculations that were done
on the resolution of this so i knew
calculations on the other side of the
riemann hilbert correspondence which
were done by mustafa the cataldo
meteorin so i was using that i was just
trying to mimic the calculation of the d
module side
and
basically the only things that i know
how to compute when i push forward the
modules is i don't have to compute other
characteristics
and
because you always get some complexes
you have to compute the homology of
those complexes the terms in the
complexes are some locally free shapes
which are not necessarily split so
i don't know how to actually do the
computation explicitly i know how to
compute other characteristics and
because some other people did the
calculation on the other side
i was able to match them
uh the question yeah yeah so i guess
like
is there
even a conjectural
connection
between this this work and the the
motivating problem that you
if you can compute local homology then
you get lower bound
this technique is going to give you
local chromology for segres it's going
to give local in other situations that
was not no that's not known in those
other situations by other means
for mages it was no but i don't think we
know for segregation
so have you done it yeah it met the
crank so i don't know i don't think we
know the argument rank for veronese
but have you done say three factor
segregation i don't know
other question
so if not we can think